well good evening how nice to be able to
do something like a reading last time I
was here I came to talk about President
Clinton but I'm not gonna mention him
today was last sigh is not as narrated
by man called mores Sugoi be known as
nicknamed war hence the title and he
tells the story of his eccentric family
a family half half Jewish half Catholic
ha both from South India his father the
father's side of the family was Jewish
the mother's side of the family were
millionaire spice traders and he was the
offspring of variously monstrous father
and mother so I'm just going to read you
two or three little bits about it to
give you some flavor of it and I'm gonna
start off with a little bit about his
maternal grandfather kalashnikova now
the names of Portuguese derivation of
many Indian Catholic families and in
this case because the family alleges
descent from the great explorer Vasco da
Gama which may or may not be true anyway
at this point
grandfather como is feeling a little
left wing it was grandfather Chemosh who
found out about the fake bouillon offs
in late 1923 he informed his wife Belle
and their friends that an elite group of
Soviet actors had been given exclusive
rights to the role of VI Lenin not only
in specially prepared touring
productions which told the Soviet people
about their Glorious Revolution but also
at the thousands upon thousands of
public functions at which the leader was
unable to be present during to the
pressures on his time the Lenin thesp
smelled and then delivered the speeches
of the great man and when they appeared
in full makeup and costume people
shouted cheered bowed and quaked as if
they were in the
of the real thing and now commercial
sighted Lee announced applications from
foreign language actors are being
solicited we can have our personal
Lennon's right here properly accredited
speaking Malayalam or tulu or Canada or
any damn thing we please it is a
demonstration of the ludicrous yes I
dare to use that word the ridiculous and
ludicrous perversity of my family but in
a period when the country and indeed the
planet was engaged in such momentous
Affairs and when the family business
needed the most scrupulous attention and
when to crown it all his own wife had
announced her pregnancy and was bearing
what turned out to be not only their
firstborn but also their only child the
only child what is more of her
generation
my mother Aurora the last of the da
Gama's then at this time my grandfather
should become increasingly obsessed with
this question of counterfeit Lenin's
with what zeal he scoured the locality
to discover men with the necessary
acting skill memory capacity and
interest in his plan with what
dedication he worked getting copies of
the latest statements of the illustrious
leader finding translators acquiring the
services of makeup artists and
costumiers and rehearsing his little
troupe of seven whom bel with her
customary brutality had dubbed the two
tall Lenin the two short Lenin the two
fat Lenin the two skinny Lenin the two
lame Lenin the two bold Lenin and Lenin
the toothless
kibosh correspond did feverishly with
contacts in Moscow cajoling and
persuading certain coach Indian
authorities both pale and dark-skinned
were likewise persuaded and cajoled and
finally in the hot season of 1924 he had
his reward
when Bell was bursting with child that
arrived in coach in a genuine
card-carrying member of the special
Lenin troop a Lenin first class with the
power to approve had further instruct
the members of the troops new coach in
branch he came by ship from Bombay and
when he walked down the gangway in
character there were little gasps and
shrieks from the dockside to which he
responded with a series of magnanimous
BIOS and waves commotion noticed that he
was perspiring freely in the heat little
rivulets of hair dye ran down his
forehead and neck and had constantly to
be mocked
how may I address you asked Kailash
blushing politely as he met his guest
who was travelling with an interpreter
no formality comrade said the
interpreter no honorifics a simple
vladimir ilyich will suffice the crowd
had gathered at the dockside to watch
the arrival of the world leader and now
commotion a little theatrical gesture of
his own clapped his hands and out of the
arrivals shed came the seven local
Lenin's in their beards they stood
shuffling their feet of the dockside
gridding sweetly at their Soviet
colleague who burst
however into long fuse of Arts of russia
vladimir Ilyich asks what is the meaning
of this outrage
the interpreter told kibosh as the crowd
around them enlarged these persons have
blackness of skin and their features are
not his too tall too short too fat too
skinny too lame to bald that one has no
teeth I was informed said kibosh
unhappily that we were permitted to
adapt the leaders image to local needs
more parishes of Russia
vladimir Ilyich opens that this is not
adaptation but satirical caricature the
interpreter said see two beards at least
are improperly affixed in spite of the
admonishing presence of the proletariat
a report will be made at the highest
level
under no circumstances do you have
authority to proceed commotions face
fell and seeing him on the point of
tears his dreams in ruins his actors his
Carter's left forward eager to
demonstrate the care with which they had
learned their roles they began to strike
attitudes and acclaim in malayalam
kannada tulu Konkani Tamil Telugu and
English they proclaimed the revolution
they demanded the immediate departure of
the revanchist foodle zuv colonialism
the blood sake cockroaches of
imperialism to be followed by the common
ownership of assets and the annual /
fulfillment of rice quotas their right
hand index finger stabbed towards the
future while their left fists rested
magisterially against their hips
babbling Lennon's their beards coming
loose in the heat addressed the now
enormous crowd which began little by
little at first and then in a great
swelling tide took a fall vladimir
ilyich turned purple
Leninist vie to operations issued from
his mouth and hung in the air above his
head in Cyrillic script
then spinning on his heel he talked back
up the gangway and disappeared below
decks What did he say
kibosh disconsolately asked the Russian
interpreter this country of yours
the interpreter replied vladimir Ilyich
tells frankly that it gives to him the
shits
well that's grandpa his daughter Aurora
grows up to be a famous painter and and
[ __ ] and this is a bit of art and then
she is the mother of the narrator so he
has a problem this is this is a bit
about her just a little bit about her my
mother
Aurora's oh boy B was too bright a star
look at her too hard and you'd be
blinded even now in the memory she
dazzles must be circled about and about
we may perceive her indirectly in her
effects on others her bending of other
people's light her gravitational pull
which denied us all hope of escape the
decaying orbits of those too weak to
withstand her and who fell towards her
son and it's consuming fires are the
dead the unending endlessly ending dead
how long how rich is their story
we the living must find what space we
can alongside them the giant dead whom
we cannot tie down though we grasp it
their hair though we rope them while
they sleep mother nurse excuse me if I
underline this point is a big idea in
India may be our biggest the Landers
mother the mother as land as the firm
ground beneath our feet ladies gents I'm
talking major mother country
the year I was born Mehboob productions
all-conquering movie mother India three
years in the making 300 shooting days in
the top three all-time mega grossing
Bollywood flicks hit the nation screens
nobody who saw it ever forgot that
gluttonous saga of peasant heroine ISM
that super slushie owed to the uncross
ability of village Indian made by the
most cynical urbanites in the world and
as for its leading lady Oh
Nargis with your shovel over your
shoulder and your strand of black hair
tumbling forward over your brow
she became until in their agony
supplanted her the living mother goddess
of us all or or a new her of course like
every other luminary of the time the
actress was drawn towards my mother's
blazing flame but they didn't hit it off
perhaps because Aurora could not refrain
from raising the subject how close to my
own heart of mother-son relations the
first time I saw that picture she
confided to the famous movie star on the
high terrace at her home I took one look
at your bad Sun build you and I thought
oh boy what a handsome guy too much
sizzle too much chilly bring water he
may be a thief and a bounder but that is
some a class loverboy goods and now look
you have gone and married him what sexy
lives you movie people leader fight to
marry your own son I swear
WOWY the film actor under discussion
Sunil Dutt stood stiffly beside his wife
and sipped lemonade flushing in those
days Bombay was a dry state and even
though whisky soda was plentiful at our
house the actor was making a moral point
or Oh Rajee you are mixing truth and
make believe he said pompously
as if it were a sin Birju
bill Jew and his mother Radha's are
fictions only in two dimensions on this
silver screen but we are flesh and blood
available in full 3d as guests in your
fine home Nargis sipping nimbu pani
smiled a thin smile at the rebuke hidden
in the last phrase even in the picture
but Arora went relentlessly on I knew
right off that that bad build you had
the hots for his gorgeous mouth Nargis
stood speechless open mouthed the artist
Vasco Myranda who could never resist a
bit of troublemaking
saw the storm brewing and made haste to
join in he offered sublimation of mutual
parent-child longings is deep-rooted in
national psyche the use of names in this
picture makes this meaning clear this
bill Jew name is also used by the god
Krishna isn't it and we know that the
milkmaid Radha is the blue God's one
true love in the picture Sunil you are
even made up to look like the God and
you fool with all the girls throwing
your stones to break their womb be water
pots which you must admit is Krishna s
clavia in this interpretation therefore
Mother India is the dark side of the
Radha Krishna story with the subsidiary
theme of forbidden love added on but
what the hell Oedipus Oedipus have
another topic dirty talks at the living
mother goddess filthy dirty cheap I
heard tell that depraved artists and
beatnik intellectuals came up here but I
gave you all the benefit of the doubt
now I observed that I am amongst the
blaspheming scum of the earth how you
people wallow in negative images in our
picture we put stress on the positive
side courage of the masses is there also
dance bad language amused Vasko
innocently good for you but in the final
cut the censor must have removed it
idiot shouted sunil dutt provoked beyond
endurance bloody Dumbo not hosts but new
technology is being referred to to wit
the hydroelectric project as inaugurated
by my good wife in the opening scene
and when you say your wife ever helpful
vasco clarified you mean of course your
mother sunil come said the legend
sweeping off if this godless
anti-national gang is the world of art
then I throw I'm happy to be on
commercial side so that's meeting of two
Mother India
I'm just going to read you two little
bits about Aurora and the character of
Vasco Miranda the the other artists in
the story were always of course good
artists vasco turns out for the bad one
later in the novel he becomes in a way
the kind of villain of the piece but at
this point he isn't at this point
they're friends but at this point she's
about to employ him on an isfahan iran
in the cupola at the corner of the high
terrace aurora was reclining in an
approximation of the clothed maja
position when vasco was brought before
her at sunset she was sipping french
champagne and smoking an imported
cigarette through a long amber holder
with her swollen belly she's pregnant at
this point propped up on silken cushions
he fell in love with her before she had
spoken fell for her as he had meant
never to fall for any woman and in his
falling set in motion a great deal of
what would follow as a spurned lover he
would become a darker man I've been
looking for a painter Aurora told him I
am he said vasco strike eagle attitude
but Aurora cut him short house painter
she said a little brutally nursery
requires to be decorated in no time flat
are you up to it speak up base generous
in this house
Moscow Miranda was deflated but also
broke after a few seconds he flashed her
his most dazzling smile and inquired
your preferred subjects Madame cartoons
she told him looking vague you go to the
pictures you read comic cuts then that
mouse that duck and what is the name of
that bunny also that sailor and his sad
saga maybe the cat that never catches
the mouse the other cat that never
catches the bird or the other bird that
runs too fast for the koi ode
give me boulders that only temporarily
flat afire you when they drop down on
your head
bombs that give black faces only and
running over empty air until you look oh
down give me not too fine up rifle
barrels and bath Falls of big gold coins
never mind about harps and angels forget
all those stinking perfume gardens for
my kiddies this is the Paradise I want
autodidact Vasco just up from Goa knew
next to nothing about wicked woodpeckers
or pesky wabbits
in spite of having no idea what aurora
was talking about however he grinned and
bowed Madame money talks
you have the hit fortune to be
addressing the absolutely greatest
number one in the parade paradise
painter in Bombay hit fortune Aurora
wondered like hit take hit Alliance hit
Conception hit areas vasco explained
opposite of miss well Velasco has a
Moscow has a drinking problem I'll just
read you a bit about his drinking
problem permit me to clarify a point
about vascular and ER from the very
start they were frightening signs that
not all the bats in his belfry were
harmless we who loved him
would gloss over the times when an
aggressive fury would pour out of him
when he seemed to crackle with such a
current of dark negative electricity
that we feared to touch him lest we
stuck to him and burned out he went on
dreadful benders and would turn up
unconscious in some gutter or wandering
dazed around the SAS even fish dock
drunk drugged bruised bleeding robbed
and giving off a terrible fishy stench
which could not be washed off in the
days when he became successful and the
darling of the International moneyed art
establishment it took a lot of hush
money to keep these episodes out of the
newspapers especially because there were
indications that many of the partners he
found on these bisexual or phix fries
were afterwards less than happy about
their experiences
there was a Hell in Vasco born of
whatever devil deal he had done to shed
his past and be born again through us
and at times he seemed capable of
bursting into flames
I am the grand old Duke of York he would
say well he was better when I am up I'm
up when I am down I am down also by the
way I have had ten thousand men the ten
thousand women - on the night of India's
independence the red mist came over him
in a rush the contradictions of that
high moment tore him apart that
celebration of freedom whose end golfing
emotions he could not avoid even though
as a Goan he was technically not
involved and which to his horror was
taking place while great blood rivers
were still flowing in the Punjab
destroyed the fragile equilibrium at the
heart of his invent itself and set the
madman free that was the way my mother
told it anyhow and no doubt that version
contains some of the truth but I know
there was also the matter of his love
for her the love he could not openly
declare which filled him up and boiled
over turning to rage he sat at the foot
of Aurora at Abraham's long and
glittering table glaring at the many
distinguished and excited guests and
drank Vinho Verde in quantity and at
speed sunk in darkness as midnight burst
in showers of light across the sky his
mood grew ever blacker until deeply
drunk he rose unsteadily to his feet and
showered the guests with blurry spittle
flecked abuse what are you all so
pleased about he shouted swaying this is
bloody McCauley is malignant
don't you get it bunch of the
english-medium misfits the lot of you
minority group members square peg freaks
you don't belong here country is an
alien to you as if you were what's
prover lunatics
movin men you read the wrong books you
get on the wrong side in every argument
you think the wrong thoughts even your
bloody dreams grow from foreign roots
stop begging a fool of yourself busker
said Arora
everybody here is shocked by the Hindu
Muslim killings you have no monopoly on
that pain only on Vinho Verde and on
being a righteous bomb which would have
stopped most people that it did not stop
poor driven Bosco crazed by history lava
the torment of keeping up the great
pretense of himself useless [ __ ] our
Johny Lever dicks each eared leaning
sideways of a dangerous angle circular
sexual India my foot know but Eve don't
whisper came back wrong secular
socialist under G so do that stuff like
a cheap watch salesman and you all
bought one now you wonder why it doesn't
work
bloody Congress party full of bloody
fake Rolex watch salesman
you think India will just roll over all
the bloody not thirsty blood-soaked gods
will just roll over and die our great
hostess Aurora great lady
great artist she thinks she could dance
those gods away and does Jesus Christ
Miranda said Abraham rising that's
enough and I'll tell you something mr.
big business manager
Bosco said beginning to give up let me
give you a hint only one power in this
damn country is strong enough to stand
up against those gods
it isn't like if he black curve circular
specialism desert like a tee blaq bunted
narrow and his light at his life
protection of minority coverage watch
what us you know what it is I tell you
what it is corruption you get me right
buddy act he lost his balance and fell
backwards - bearers in gold button white
yellow jackets held him preparing to
remove him from the party at Abraham's
signal but Abraham's a very paused and
allowed the ceiling to play itself out
Johnny oh damn fine bribery and grease
said faster in cheerful tones as if
speaking of an old and beloved dog
backhanders payoffs sweetness you follow
me
ABG are you with me me Miranda's
definition of democracy one man one
block
that's the way that's the big secret
that's it his hands rushed to his mouth
with something alarm
oh you bit me stupid stupid mask oh it's
no secret
Abraham G being set up buddy big shot of
course he knows it all
such a bloody big grand brother sucking
so many bloody big eggs apologies please
to excuse Abraham nodded the white
jackets hooked their arms under his
armpits and began to drag vascular
backwards one more thing
Baskin rolled so loudly that the bearers
faltered he hung in their arms like a
stuffed doll waving an insane finger
piece of good advice for y'all get on
the boats with the British just get on
the bloody boat son bugger off this
place has no use for you it'll eat you
and eat you get out get out while the
getting is good and you abraham asked
standing with Styria courtesy in the
shot silence you Vasco what advice do
you have for yourself
Oh me kiss I got just the white coats
born in a way don't worry about me I'm
Portuguese
all right if people would like to line
up to if you wouldn't mind going to the
the microphones that way we don't have
to repeat everything that people want to
ask mr. Rushdie so there in the middle
there there and we'll try to be fair
well let's start with this gentleman
over there yes I'm at Syed the Egyptian
correspondent here in Washington I would
like to ask you about what the Jimenez
fatwa what is the situation now with
this [ __ ] from Iran thank you oh
well fortify they say I think the answer
is that it's very that I don't know
because as you'll probably know the
Iranians for the last many months have
been embarking on a kind of charm
offensive to point out to us that not
only do they not wish to kill anybody
but actually they never wanted to it
would be nice if they told us before
however whatever the European Union has
asked them to write this down and they
appeared to have a reluctance to do so
this in my view somewhat undermines the
credibility of what they're saying
because I mean put it this way if I if I
wanted to murder you and you asked for
it in writing I would not have I mean I
would have a difficulty in writing it
down only if in fact I did want to
murder you
if I didn't we'd be relatively simple to
say I didn't so that's where we are I
don't know what lessons to draw from
this but the the fact is that I'm I'm
losing interest
I'm Ramachandran from Times of India
many of your characters in this book
seems to have been inspired by real-life
characters in India or now so I wondered
one of the character is Bal Thackeray
who's the head of the right-wing
organization in Bombay and he seems to
have issued his own fatwa which says
that the most lasts I should not be read
in India so many of your fans are in
India a family deprived of reading this
book what what do you feel about this
yeah well I mean Bal Thackeray and the
Chiefs I know clearly have have not seen
the joke it does it does and it did
occur to me that since mr. Thackeray
began his career as a political
cartoonist he he should be acquainted
with the concept of satire but I guess
it's different when you're the target
and I would just make the point that of
course the character of Rahman fielding
in in the novel is in part based on
Thackeray after all fielding and
Thackeray have something in common and
they and they're both political
cartoonists I mean those are the things
that they have in common apart from
being fascist thugs I mean a point I may
say which I suspect mr. Thackeray would
agree with because I interviewed members
of the Shiv Sena when I was at Bombay in
1987 and when I when I asked them if
they were that he was this particular
chap was in a documentary I made but I
asked him if he was a fascist he said
yes I have a fascist and when I asked to
be who's the racist he said yes we are
racists and after we had finished
filming this episode I remember saying
to him that look you know you have said
all this stuff on the record and we will
therefore use it and he looked at me
puzzled as to you why was I asking this
question he said listen said ideology is
okay so the point is these guys don't
mind being called this so to go back to
your question what's happened in India
is a particularly Indian fudge after
after Thakur A's well I'm not sure
thorium said much himself but after the
ships and I said a number of things on
chakras behalf the Indian government
hasn't done anything is as
clear as banning the book what they did
is on the one hand I was asked for 15
signed copies for members of the Indian
government and and Prime Minister
Narasimha Rao was seen reading the
Mohr's last sigh approvingly on an
airplane but meanwhile they made it
impossible for anybody else to get a
copy by basically creating a blockade in
the customs and when we have asked them
why they are preventing the import of
further books they say that they are
discussing the advisability of the
import of further copies and when we
asked them how long it will take them to
discuss this they stopped answering our
letters and phone calls so this is a
classic technique of wrap it up in red
tape and throw it in the corner and hope
everyone forgets it well this time I'm
afraid people won't forget it and I mean
if necessary we will do this through the
courts and I would hope the Indian
courts would would demand that rather
rapidly that the government shows cause
why it's doing this thing and I don't
really think that there is a cause I
mean after all if Indian democracy has
reached the point at which one
politicians objection to a novel can
result of the banning of that novel then
that's that's the poor state of affairs
so I mean I remain sort of reasonably
confident that we will be able to fight
this but I mean I can't tell you how
depressing it is for me that after this
novels initial reception in in India and
indeed in Bombay was so wonderful that
that that further people in India should
be prevented from having access to it
that I hope will win this fight
it's just a shame there is one I'm an
old Russia with the Financial Express
from India I have two questions one is
the first no.1
which relates to your the property
you've just got back through the courts
in Solon are you ever do you ever hope
to ever live there again my second
question is more complicated and that
relates to I think a bit of the history
it goes back to the Satanic Verses do
you think now this is something which
you must have gone through many times in
the past when you wrote the verses when
you refer to the verses for which the
Ayatollah issued a fatwa
against you what are you using it as a
literary device to shock were you
conscious that this would be something
which would shock and therefore it with
an act of deliberation in that point of
view because many of us in India at that
particular point in time thought that
well
Salman should have known better and I'm
sure you've gone through these arguments
in the in the past these questions in
the past but I was just wondering if you
could sort of for the audience here come
back to this again okay well just
quickly the first question now in that
the question of the house and in Solan
is not resolved yet because although
it's been put back into my father's name
that the question of whether my father's
gift of the house to me is legal it's
still being kind of argued about by the
Indian government and and we still have
to prove that point it seems seems
extraordinary petty of them when we were
previously able to prove that government
officers had perjured themselves and
falsified documents it seems that they
might have had the grace to give him
quietly but what knows much luck and yes
of course I hope to go back to India I
mean whether to oh we never of course
lived in the house and so long it's a
summer cottage but it would be very nice
to have it to have it available again
and on the larger question of the
Satanic Verses which I must say I've
only answered approximately one in 1
million in one times but for the million
in second time first of all I'm not
exactly sure what is so wrong about
shocking people and I think the question
of knowing better that's to say is is is
is is the argument of a culture that
wants a completely Placid and emollients
literature I mean it doesn't seem to me
that that's what the function of
literature is what did I think I was
doing I thought I was writing my own
reckoning with the subjective of
religion and I make no bones about the
fact that my reckoning with with that
subject is not divided at the same time
it seems to me that what I did was
completely legit
I mean it's it's the stuff in the novel
is can be shown to be based on on a
great deal of previously existing
scholarship about the nature of the
origins of Islam it just happens to be
historicist and dissented it happens to
be put it like this if you want me to
say that if that if I had been standing
beside the Prophet Mohammed on Mount
Hira outside makana that I would have
seen the Archangel Gabriel appear to him
and give him the words of the Quran I
have to say that I would not I do not
think that I would have seen the
Archangel no now if that's blasphemy
then that's blasphemy you know so be it
I mean it still happens to be a point of
view that seems legitimate now what
follows from that point of view since it
also seems to be quite clear that the
Prophet was not making it up is is to
ask oneself what's going on what is the
nature of this phenomenon revelation and
that's just not that's not only Islam
that's any revelation and since I'm a
novelist the way in which I do that is
to try and enter the character and and
understand it from the inside understand
the process from the inside now people
don't like that they don't like that you
know on the other hand nobody made him
read it of course they didn't read it
that's not a matter I mean one of the
things I think is that a lot of
intellectuals in India and elsewhere
initially failed to say very much in my
defense because of this quietest
argument I mean if only the world was a
quiet place it is not and one of the
things I think is valuable now if you
like in this was like aftermath of the
storm that there are things being
written and said including by Muslim
intellectuals about the Satanic Verses
which are much much more straightforward
you know in terms of their intellectual
approach to the book I mean there was
some of you may have seen the book that
was published here in English
translation a year before last call for
Rushdie which in which something like a
hundred and ten or so of the most
important intellectuals in the Muslim
world defended either me or my
and in all cases my right to speak in
that way I met recently in Sweden a
professor of English literature of
literature rather from from Damascus in
Syria who told me rather impressively I
thought that he had begun to teach a
course in The Satanic Verses in Damascus
I asked him if he was alright and and
and if his students were well and and he
said no it's a very popular course so
all I'm saying is that gradually this
book is being restored to the condition
of literature and being studied in that
way and you know it may and it is the
case already that there are Muslims who
like it you know III do want to stress
this thing that a very strange thing
happened with the Satanic Verses
that it seemed as if only the people who
did not like the novel had the right to
talk about it you know I I mean what it
perhaps the only occasion I think in the
history of literature when only the bad
review has got listened to I mean this
is a novel that many people liked
including many people in India and many
Muslim readers why don't we listen to
them why is their view not as important
as the view of the people who want to
commit acts of violence the question is
not whether I should have known better
but whether it is legitimate to attack a
novel and its author and it's publishers
in this way and in my view it is not
yes I am Phil willing with the Tampa
Tribune and I have a two quick questions
one is how long did it take you take us
to write the book and secondly how does
the story or Moore's predicament how has
it resembled your life over the past
several years well the book took on and
off five years to write you know you
know that which is that not that unusual
for me actually because the Satanic
Verses took five years to write and and
Midnight's Children took five years to
write so for these sort of these fatter
books of mine that seems that seems
about my speed it's it is true that at
this time it was very interrupted period
of five years because well the part
where the else the political campaigning
that I was involved in interrupted the
writing of the book considerably for the
first three years at least and it was
only after actually was after the last
time I was here after I came to meet
President Clinton and then came to talk
about it I felt you know that's enough
politicians IDI I felt it was time to to
stop shaking hands and politicians and
to go back and and do my work and it was
after that the novel began to write
itself fluently and as to how well how
much is it to do with me I mean not very
much really he's got a deformed right
hand
I haven't he commits acts of incredible
violence with it and I didn't and he
finds himself leading a life which goes
twice as fast as everybody else's so
he's 72 years old at the age of 36 and
that's not true of me because I'm 150 I
think to Brants the question seriously
it's it's always the case that if you
use a first-person point of view
narrator that that some of your thoughts
and feelings come out through his
through his mouth and through his
thoughts I mean why would you otherwise
use such a such a narrator but that's
the that's the extent to which he's me
you know in the way that I don't know
Moses Hertzog is not Saul Bellow
you know Stephen Dedalus is not James
Joyce Marcel is not Proust but they all
share some characteristics
creators and I suppose that's that's as
close as it is I mean this is not a
novel I must say just in case anybody
wants to read it and for that reason and
gets disappointed this is not a novel
about what happened to me in the last
seven years it's a novel about what
happened to these people in the last
seven years and the time that I write
about what happened to me I will not
write about it as fiction because I
think what is important about the so
called Rushdie case is that it's true is
that it really happened and there's a
lot about it that is not in the public
domain and I look forward to to telling
it's very it's very odd to be a writer
with a hot story and to have to sit on
it mr. Rushdie so far you've been
discussing the reaction of a several
thoughtful what are two US foreign
governments to your work but here we are
in the United States of America where
the Congress has recommended a massive
cut in the National Endowment for the
Arts and is trying to get the American
government out of any kind of support
for art and for the intangible benefits
of citizenry and I'd like to know from
your point of view how this seems to you
now well it's it it seems it seems wrong
to me I mean certainly I'm not fully
aware of the exact details of what's
being proposed but I'm aware of the the
attack on the national of the NEA budget
and and and certainly I would be
absolutely opposed to that I mean
there's a very similar struggle going on
in in Britain where the where the much
smaller budget provided for the Arts
Council is also under constant and an
increasing threat I mean I I found
myself recent theater at a meeting of
various Arts Council figures including
the the chairman and it was seriously
proposed that they said it apparently is
the view of the present chairman of the
Arts Council in Britain that the budget
for literature for example should be
spent promoting dead writers rather than
living writers that the job of promoting
living writers should be done by
publishers and that the Arts Council
back the dead ones this is this is uh
this is what you get from the government
on its last legs I guess they'll all be
dead right as soon but I mean of course
I'm completely opposed to the the
cutting of arts funding I can't comment
in more details I really don't know the
case you know that the Congress has
recommended that the only fellowships
left to individuals are those in
literature so that is one thing that
does still remain at this juncture yeah
mr. Rushdie I'm Shankar vedantam with
nightroad and newspapers sort of
following up on the previous question
that was asked of whether the novel was
autobiographical in any sense there were
a couple of passages that struck me just
brief sentences one where Moore says I
stopped being afraid because if my time
on earth was limited I didn't have
seconds to spare for funk another
instance where the painters a painting
has been protested against by this
fundamentalist in Bombay and Shera you
write or the character rights
it became however an albatross and a
witness both have fury at having to
endlessly to defend it and her fury at
the ease of which this teapot monsoon
had distracted attention from the body
of her real work mm-hmm
but those two passages are a
biographical yeah I think I'll own up to
both of those
as I said there are there are some of
those bits but you will note that those
two passages describe the lives of two
different characters so it would be
different difficult to point to decide
which of the two was the
autobiographical character particularly
since one of them's female yeah actually
in my view the female character is moral
to biographical than the male one that's
to say the the effort of inventing a
painter or aura to whom the the the
trouble before the to which you've just
for which you've just quoted clearly is
his only part was only possible to me by
trying to rethink into the into the art
of painting some of the ideas that I
myself have tried to work with in in the
art of literature so I mean Aurora is if
that's safe if I was a painter I might
be her if she was a writer you know she
might be better than me you mentioned
some time ago that if you wrote about
your own life it wouldn't be fiction
something that struck me when I've been
reading your work is that a lot of your
work is political allegory a lot of your
work is is fairy tales but it's really
real political stories dressed up as
fairy tales do you see your own life in
some way as as being a very roughly
asked story yes it's it's a bad one
though if I was writing it I'd write it
better than this
III think that the truth is that if I
had proposed as the plot of a novel the
action of the last seven years I think
people would have laughed at its
implausibility and one of the things
that is disturbing about the passage of
those seven years is that what was
unthinkable seven years ago has become
thinkable what what seemed absolutely
impossible to imagine that such a thing
could happen you know now not only has
it happened to me and survived I've gone
on for long time it's happened to lots
of other people you know and and and one
of the points I tried to make right at
the begin
this was that if one does not counter
threats of this sort then you are making
sure that they will be repeated and and
since the mainly fatwa against against
me as you know there have been other
[ __ ] laws against other writers in
Bangladesh and elsewhere in Algeria in
Iran itself in Egypt you know a
supposedly moderate country Egypt but
nevertheless there is there is trouble
of this sort so unfortunately we seem to
find ourselves facing a new kind of
threat
you know remote control terrorism where
all you have to do is point a finger
across the world and say you know him
and it's still important to stand up
against all this for that reason it's
important to stand up for the scheme on
a screen and not be sidetracked into the
issue of whether she's a good or a bad
writer you know even bad writers deserve
to live well most bad writers
one one final question if I may sir and
that's about the writing itself a lot of
the writing seems extremely abstruse and
a lot of the puns especially that you
make a lot of the bilingual puns must
miss a lot of your readers especially a
lot of your Western readers one of your
characters was named merchant dal Cheney
which is a hilarious pun if you know
that Mitch and dal Sunni are the names
of two Indian spices it seems in some
ways you you're laughing at the reader
in some ways for not cashing on is that
right no it's not right it's just a joke
you know people don't get all your jokes
and you know the people who I mean if
you if you're kind enough to say that
the joke is funny if you understand it
then well there's your answer
really the joke is funny if you
understand it there's plenty of there
are plenty of things in books from
countries other than the ones that I
know about that I'm sure I miss you know
III gather from people who know much
more about Latin America than I do that
if you read if they read One Hundred
Years of Solitude for example they can
decode every reference in it in terms of
the same kind of illusion and joke well
I don't get there is I still enjoy the
novel you know people who people who
read who read the tin drum for instance
said very similar things about its its
wealth of illusion and its Arcana if you
like
well that's nice for them you know but
it doesn't stop me having access to the
novel in the same way somebody who knows
who reads Midnight's Children knows
Hindi and knows that there are new of
kuch nahi is the Rani of nothing at all
we'll have a we'll have a good time
since specially since it's a pun on a
really existing Rani of cooch behar but
that's that's just it's just an aside it
doesn't make any difference to the story
and it's just flavoring you know spices
thank you
speaking in my capacity as a former
English major at one of the Kings
colleges of the eastern United States I
want I have a question about the general
topic of race relations and
multiculturalism in the United States
two quick reasons why I raised that
topic and then the question I noticed
that you move very quickly back and
forth between accents and that suggests
a multicultural ease and familiarity and
secondly not having had any direct
contact with India never living there I
would never have guessed known what to
think about the Catholic presence the
Jewish presence the Portuguese presence
I mean I drew a complete blank on that
and saw the complexity so I wonder what
your perceptions of race relations and
multiculturalism in the United States
are through the lenses of of India and
and Saudi Arabia excuse me India and
England um two nations I know you're
familiar with but there's so much
everything from Clarence Thomas to to OJ
Simpson that anything you can shed on
that and any other person I'm not
particularly asking about them in that
area right well how long have you got um
it's it's two bigger questions all I can
do is say something focus in on
literature again well what I think is
that areas of discussion and writing
about race or arising out of racial
difference and so on have become a kind
of minefield of the United States it
seems you know it does it does seem as
if walls get erected around around
subject matter and people have to defend
their right to speak about this or that
subject I'm afraid I I misbehave rather
a lot in that area you know because I'm
not very good at at keeping out of areas
I'm supposed to not go into in fact
they'd rather attract me when people
build walls around them and I mean I I
would say only this that I grew up in in
in
and in a city above all in which
cultural mixture was simply well it was
so much the norm that it was it's even
impossible to conceive of a separation
between them
I mean of my family was very loosely
Muslim but mercifully free of religion
the the I mean my my of my father's two
best friends one was a Hindu and the
other was a Jew I certainly didn't get
brought up at any kind of closed
community and it seemed to me then and
it seems to me now that the that the
nature of the modern metropolis is that
mixture know in that that the one of the
characters in the Satanic Verses says at
one point that the city is the the locus
classic ershov incompatible realities
that they that they sit next to each
other on the bus you know they bump into
each other in the street and most of the
time that's a rich experience in my view
most of the time that's an enriching
experience to be constantly bumped into
by difference every so often those
differences collide in the in a slightly
head-on way and then you get an
explosion and that happens of course in
India as well as everywhere else but on
the whole I'm for it
I it's difficult to say more than that
without writing a novel so so I wrote a
novel and here it is
thank you my name is Joseph Polikoff I
write for Jewish newspapers at the very
outset of your remarks you spoke about a
Jewish Catholic Union of some sort and I
was wondering how you arrived at this in
an Indian because of the paucity of of
numbers in India yeah of Jews and
Catholics you just mentioned about a
friend being a Jew which is intriguing
as well but on a larger question if I
may ask is the question of the rise of
Islamic fundamentalism in Europe the
embattlement in Russia the rise of it in
the United States as well and how do you
anticipate or expect should we say a
furtherance of this movement towards
domination or control or a strong voice
in a politics of what had been for more
than 400 years absent from Europe and
its fan of the United States of course
well the first question first so and I
began this novel by wanting to write
about the Walton begin my novel at the
point of first contact between European
Europeans European culture and India and
that was the arrival of Vasco da Gama
and his ships in first in Calcutta and
then in Cochin in the in the southwest
of India and it struck me as being well
more than interesting it struck me as
being stimulating to my juices if you
like that the reason for that visit that
first visit was not initially conquest
although conquest later took place it
was not in the first place looking for
gold you know there was not like the
conquistadores and in Latin America
looking for El Dorado although later on
there was economic exploitation they
came to pepper I mean they they came for
spices and that was all but primarily
for pepper and I thought well if this
entire extraordinary history of the
meeting between Europe and India was
built on a peppercorn
No then then that would be a reason to
begin a novel in that place and to try
and grow a novel out of a peppercorn and
if you look at the history of the spice
trade inside in that part of India then
actually the Jewish and the Jewish and
the Indian Jewish and the Indian
Catholic communities were historically
very involved with that indeed in many
ways still are so that was one reason
why it seemed quite natural to have to
use these small communities as a central
as a central plank of the novel but
there was another reason to which is
that there is a kind of increasing
rhetoric in in India and as you rightly
say not only in India of the
dictatorship of the majority and an
attempt to say that only the reality or
the experience of the 85 percent Hindu
majority in India is somehow authentic
experience I thought if we it would be
both valuable and novelistic ly
interesting to stand that proposition on
its head and to take two of the smallest
communities in the country created even
smaller community by intermarrying them
doesn't happen very often and thus
creating a kind of hybrid and ultra
minority and then instead of having that
at the edge of the frame to move that
into the center of the frame and show
that you could actually grow the whole
reality of the country out of it and
very far from being you know inauthentic
or immigrant or spurious that it was in
fact as central and Indian experience as
anything else so there was that
intention to as to the larger question
of the growth of fundamentalism I mean
all I can say is that it is growing I
mean I think it's I must be clear to
anyone in the United States and it's
growing here too well so whether it's
Christian fundamentalism here or Muslim
fundamentalism elsewhere or Hindu
fundamentalism in India it seems to be a
moment at which people want simple
answers and they're willing to to use
force in their service and I think I
mean I don't have a simple solution to
it I think all one can do as a writer is
go on pointing it out and arguing
against it and that's certainly
something I would hope to do